uh
all right chris welcome back
so i found you on the street not far
from my studio here on skid row again
yeah you know your family came out here
a week or so ago
looking for you and you know i i tried
to
find you when they were here but that
didn't work out but i found you shortly
after and i've seen you since
yeah you uh were you open to i mean i
asked you at the time if you wanted to
get together with them
um well
i
got a call from him and i
was supposed to go see him
but i didn't
and it was
dumb of me
but
it's okay
yeah i asked you the other day if you
wanted
you know i could kind of somehow connect
you and your dad or
your your family and you kind of said no
i'm good
and just walked away yeah i mean i
understand that
maybe the mental state you're in right
now you you can't really make decisions
that are in your best interest yeah
i've spoken to your dad several times
about what we could do about that but
are you open to any kind of help or any
kind of assistance in getting off the
street or maybe getting back together
with them or into a hospital or the care
of a doctor or anything like that
oh no i don't mind standing on the
streets
you're getting in a lot of fights every
time i see you you got a black eye or
scraped up or something
no i just got into one fight just one
i mean i see how you're living out here
on the streets it's pretty
it's very rough you're basically just
sitting on concrete
yeah it's not rough
i mean for me it's not
you gotta be lonely
do you remember time in your life when
you
things were different for you do you
long for those days
do you miss those days
[Music]
well i will
you gotta call on your
phone
i'm sorry
do you miss the days when you maybe had
your life a little more
together
um
you're i'm sure you were happier at one
point in your life than you are today
well yeah
what are you smoking lately
um the corner you're at is mostly spice
spice and crack
crystal here and there
you get money where how do you get money
oh
i was stealing alcohol and clothes
but now i just
your pen handling too i think
um no
well i got a few dollars from
one lady
you go to the missions to eat
um where do you eat
i don't eat regularly
you had a garbage or stuff like that
um no
no
are you sleeping at all
um yeah
where do you sleep um
in the sidewalk just on a cardboard box
or something like that
um or just on the side
just on the sidewalk either yeah
you spoke to your family how did they
reach you
um you called them
call them that's great
how did that go because i know they're
they're trying their best to help you
you're hard to find i think
um
yeah well it's because i don't have a
phone
maybe i can get your phone okay and then
maybe you can
i'll get you your dad's number if you
don't have it
and we can go from there and
hopefully get you guys connected somehow
and maybe get you some help
all right that sounds good yeah
you know it'd be nice to have some
change because staying here where you're
at
nothing good is going to come with this
i can tell you that
all right
hi chris well thanks for coming by again
let's go get your phone and we'll uh
we'll put you on the phone with your dad
and see what uh what kind of things we
can do
okay are you open to going back
staying with your family or something
like that yeah
you are that's great i think that'd be
good for you
um excellent
it's good to hear thank you so much
you